un énorme entrepôt pour de toutes
petites plantes
ce jeune entrepreneur sem aujourd'hui ce
qu'il récoltera cet été je dois à la
table de l'entreprise de production
maraîchère en milieu urbain donc nous on
procède à l'installation des toits verts
sauf que à l'inversé des autres
compagnies d autres offrent un secteur
nous on vous venez vraiment producteurs
maraîchers dont on dépend d'autres
productions comme source de revenus à 28
ans il s'apprête à mettre sur pied le
plus grand potager sur toi en
collaboration avec le promoteur
immobilier michel dallaire ben c'est
certain que quinqua matthieu dallon nous
invite à un rendez-vous on essaie de se
libérer plus disponible jeudi à 9 heures
oui disponible jeudi à 9 heures puis je
dois être le cas nettement il ya été
surpris et je comprends que certains
bureaux pour efg disons vont nous aider
aussi
quand j'entends dans quelque chose je
m'arrange pour que ça fonctionne
la première phase de l'espace innovation
chauveau représente un investissement de
110 millions de dollars et prévoit la
construction de dix bâtiments d'une
superficie totale de plus de 8 hectares
l'aménagement en toit vert augmente la
facture d'environ 5%
le bénéfice pour nous c'est d'avancer et
de suie dénommé monétairement il est en
impôts dès l'été 2000 vingt trois
hectares de toi pourront être exploitées
c'est au dessus de tout ce qui existe
actuellement le plus grand toit
maraîchage de maraîchers qui existent
actuellement au canada ces 2500 mètres à
3 mètres carrés l'initiative de québec
est dix fois plus importante que ce
potager sur le toit de cga de montréal à
l'échelle internationale le projet le
plus imposant médiatisé devrait voir le
jour à paris l'an prochain il prévoit
l'exploitation d'un hectare et demi de
toiture vraiment notre clientèle cible
c'est les utilisateurs des bâtiments au
dessus donc le transport est nul en fait
le seul déplacement vertical dans un
ascenseur en attendant de se lancer dans
la production de plus de 1000 paniers de
légumes l'an prochain la jeune équipe du
toit la table en prêt par 150 pour cet
été c'est génial je pense que on va
encore faire pas mal de nuits blanches
mais c'est ce qu'on aime
on est motivés puis de rien on veut on
peut changer le monde et si marie maude
cambrien radio canada québec